[Music] I'm surprised that everyone sees and lists them.
Everyone tells me that they haven't sold yet, but I'm a person whose
color is white and my sister tends to turn red
.
[Music] I'm making 15.
It sells for 15 under the brand name of white jewels.
It sells for about 4000 naughty.
White jewels basically have a lot of salt in the middle of the night, but they are much
whiter and bigger.
It's a part that I don't see in the view.
People other than me don't make it as a site. It's
quite difficult to cultivate
and I can't do it even if I want to come with normal strawberry because of illness.
White strawberry is more deterrent.
Since the red color is also noticeable without coming, the probability of becoming a product is
reduced to about 1/10. It will
be a
little expensive part
. The market where both color, shape and size have increased in total balance.
I think the taste is also a wonderful part. Surprisingly, it
doesn't have such a profound impact, but it's always mysterious and delicious.
[Music]
It's been over 100 years since I started making with white jewels.
I feel happy because I can often feel that the
taste, scent and shape that I can't imagine are born.
[Music]
No, my goal is to taste strawberry and other fruits.  It's sweet or delicious, and I
have no choice but to push forward until the customer tells me that this part is definitely correct.
[Music]